[Music]
today I want to talk about how we
brought the instead of you know what
everyone's hearing about today with
service how we brought that model to to
cloud IDs and essentially we didn't do
it on purpose we almost did it
accidentally
so what repli'd is before I get into the
server stuff is repli'd is our mission
is to bring programming to more people
we want to be able to support any device
any computer out there anyone who has a
computer should be able to code
she coding should be as easy as opening
a new tab that's sort of like what what
we do and from there we kind of get
progressively more advanced and I'll
show you some of the stuff that you can
do with it with the platform so it is
essentially an online IDE for more than
50 programming languages zero set up you
can just start immediately and it's
becoming also a platform for hosting
code and hosting apps and on top of that
we have a very friendly open community
for people who are getting started with
programming and even advanced
programmers as well so I'll give a quick
demo so you know the getting started
experience is that you basically pick a
programming language I'm just gonna pick
no GS here you name it so let's say def
zone create a raffle and you're
immediately booted up with an
interactive programming environment you
see a big green run-button
and that kind of invites you to just
start coding and start doing something
on the right we have the raffle and you
can sort of it's like an interactive
repple you can define valuables you can
you know console log valuables and and
do anything you can do with the repple
but it gets a little bit more
interesting when say
a you know you want to require let's say
you copied some code from the internet
and had the library lodash repli'd will
automatically detect that and will start
installing the package so that's
something we do to just make sort of
programming a lot easier and so I can I
can use I can use any and you
immediately get really good autocomplete
as well so you don't have to setup any
you know LSP or anything like that we
just do it for you and I could run that
where it gets really interesting is that
let's say I want to get a server running
so I can do something like important
Express yes so I can go to our package
manager and import Express let me just
zoom that in the moment I hit add it
will create a package JSON for me and
we'll start installing Express by the
time I go back to that to the editor
Express is already available for me
I can't require that I can start Express
app I have an app and say enroute we're
gonna just say hello world and someone
someone's had a port for me any port
8080 I heard so any port would work the
IDE will detect that you're trying to do
web programming and will open up a web
view and now we have a website hosted a
deaf zone a mossad to repple and it just
it's caught off on your side here but it
just says a little world and that's like
hosted forever and you can come back to
it anytime I can also open a shell and I
could inspect my files from the shell
and now you might be starting to think
that this is this is running on a VM
that there's like a VM powering this in
the backend
and you can do whatever you want on him
however it's not what we do all of this
is running in a container and say I'm
gonna I'm gonna just use chrome dev
tools to put it offline so I'm gonna put
it offline it's it it's stopped loading
now put it online again everything went
back to the same state and what has
happened there is we either spun down
the container or if we spun down the
container then we're gonna start a new
container we're gonna bring all the
existing state and there's gonna be sort
of a negotiation protocol between the
IDE and the container like here's my
state I have a shell open I have a
window that I'm programming a website
open and we reconstruct the state in a
matter of milliseconds we copy the files
into the container and we spend
everything back up and this use case is
not only viable for like web programming
you could also do native application
programming so here's like the famous PI
game the famous sort of Pi game pro game
framework and I'm just gonna run one of
their examples and we're gonna stream
down VNC and start playing games in the
and the browser and so and let me go
back to the to the presentation now so
let me walk you through a little bit of
history of how we have we built this and
then I'll go into a little bit more
detail on the backend how we built our
like fake VM via serverless
model so what what we want is we want a
sandbox to execute code in we're going
to execute unsafe code data that was
given by our users and it needs to have
access to system resources anything that
you can do beyond the simple case of
practicing a program you have to
actually use system resources network
file system etc I should work everywhere
should be cross browser and shouldn't
load fast and should be extremely cheap
right now today repli'd has more than a
million monthly active programmers
in code in our platform if we were to
give VM to everyone like say you know
Google shell or some of these VMs with
with an online editor you know it's
gonna be very very costly and most of
our users don't have the money to
actually pay for that so our first pass
we're like okay since we want this cheap
what we're gonna do is we're gonna
actually like compile all the languages
to JavaScript we're gonna use Waze MJS
and we're gonna create we're gonna
emulate this POSIX layer on the client
to make it work in your browser we ran
into a lot of problems it had a huge
bundle size we had like 15 megabytes on
script bundle for like Python and all
the kind of unix interfaces and you know
if you're someone with a Chromebook
somewhere with a really bad connection
and you're downloading this much
JavaScript you're gonna run out of
memory just trying to parse the
JavaScript and it also didn't have
access to real system resources no
matter how much we try to fake it so now
we moved it to the back end but that was
that was - that was all three years ago
and serverless wasn't really a thing
like it started becoming a thing but it
wasn't even in our mind so we had to
make something that was cheap enough
that we could run so it should feel like
a VM but the VM is actually very costly
right so what we did we're like alright
we're getting it we're gonna do it run
we're gonna make it run on on-demand
containers containers to be ephemeral
anytime we we take out the set of
computing any time you're idle and the
IDE you should be able to take your to
take your container from you and only
bring you back when you're actually
executing code or you're doing something
in the IDE it shouldn't one on
preemptable Google compute engine or
anybody else spot spot instances
basically you want to run it as cheaply
as possible preemptable compute is
eighty percent cheaper so how do we do
that and it's like again it's this
ephemeral model
it should have reproducible sake like so
let's say you know we're on GCP
preemptable they take one of our
instances and you're coding on that and
a container inside that instances we
should we should be able to reconstruct
the state and should not basically feel
that that there was a change and if it
should scale up on down according to
demand so here's the architecture that
we came up with so that you know we
started building this before kubernetes
was the phenomena that it is today maybe
if we built it today we'd start with
kubernetes but when we started we're
like okay we're gonna have these this
virtual machine instances inside them
we're gonna have docker we wrote our own
container manager orchestration system
we're gonna have the files live on GCS
we're gonna have some kind of state and
Redis and that's deep and we're gonna
have a docker image registry and then
we're gonna have a proxy that actually
whenever a request comes in finds the
container and connects you to the right
container so when we start a ripple
which is what we call a project a repple
is basically a union of a docker image a
a GCS state in terms of files and some
kind of internal state about who the
user is and authorizations and what
collaborators they have and and
different things like that so that's
kind of the high-level overview of our
our back-end to dig deep a little bit
into the unto the components con man is
our container manager you can think of
it as something like like kubernetes or
docker swarm it like figures out what
needs to run where it needs to run and
creates the containers for those things
to run pin1 is a program that we inject
into the container and pin1 is basically
a in its program that we use paid one
knows how to talk or protocol and it's
responsible for reproducing the state
when you get a new container so when you
get a new container we inject this
program at runtime
that we call pin 1 it gets run and now
it's negotiate negotiating the state
with the clients in order to reproduce
it to the best of its ability and then
container registry we we like to support
a lot of languages a lot of environments
so for every environments we create a
new container and we we're constantly
updating these containers fixing bugs
releasing security issues so we use
Google container registry to be able to
to do that and storage it was like a
no-brainer to use GCS for for storage
for the proxy you saw me how when I
started a web server they just
understood that I want to serve some
external traffic and what we do is we
add some states or Redis and then our
proxy knows where to send the traffic we
we get a we get a we get a cert from
let's encrypt and we give you a GPS on
the fly and fire the state where you
know I mention it it lives on on Redis
and at the other places
[Music]